[Music]
all right let's go to mary in little
rock hey mary what's up
hey john long time listener first time
caller how are you nobody ever says that
that's fantastic
are you serious i figured a lot of
people say that no it's because i don't
have any longtime listeners
they listen once they're like i'm never
listening to that stupid show again yeah
how are you
i'm good i'm good so what's up you're
taking my call today let's save the
world okay so i'll
all right i'm gonna get in i'm gonna
give a really brief question and we can
kind of dig into it if you want to or
you might have a really brief answer so
here we go um my question is how can i
be supportive of my husband's hobbies
without feeling kind of resentful
without the fact that they mainly take
him you know away on the weekends to do
stuff
oh good question
uh okay tell me more
um so we
have been married almost three years
we've got two kids under two um we both
work
very intense full-time jobs his job uh
he has kind of erratic hours so he's
not home a lot at nights and some
weekends anyway and so that's why i kind
of put so much emphasis on our quality
time on the weekends and then
you know every few months it's like hey
i'm gonna pick up this new hobby and i'm
like why what are you doing anyway
um
okay there's a few things at play here
okay
let's see one
two kids two and under
right
or two kids under two right
yes okay
y'all are in a season
that is not gonna last forever okay
all right so i want you to like
let that be the sidewalk that we're
gonna walk on together um this season
will pass okay
the second thing is i wanna hear from
you about quality time when you talk to
your husband about quality time
tell me how that conversation goes
i mean when i say like i think we need
to spend more time together it's doing
stuff as a family and
it's not
being in the same room while he's on his
phone or you know while i'm entertaining
our kids like i really try like
i try and explain what quality time
means to me and i don't always feel like
that get hurt i guess
okay
so
i'm gonna put that i'm making myself a
little note here so i can circle back to
it okay tell me about his hobbies what
are we talking about here
uh hunting fishing
all the things that go along with those
mainly hunting and fishing so you're
we're in the summer here so we're
getting to the end of fishing i'm about
to start the hunting season and you're
already anticipating losing him for the
next few months right
well i mean i try to be understanding
about certain seasons of hunting because
it's you know it's seasonal and i know
it's only a certain period of days where
he can do certain hunting and i'm like
okay but
for example a few months ago he traded
some piece of hunting equipment for a
fishing kayak and then it became well
i'm gonna go fishing every weekend in
this new fishing kayak
so
so tell me
there's something beneath the time thing
here
what is it
what do you mean
um
he makes declarations and switches
hobbies with some regularity
so is it the spending that's driving you
crazy or is it no no it's not okay is it
the perception that
you're stuck at home like
you could say i'm just gonna go kayaking
every weekend but you are looking at
these two little kids and you think i
can't i'm here
and is it the freedom that he feels like
he has to just head out is that the
result resentment
i think that's what it is and it's not
it's not that i have all these hobbies
that i want to be doing because you know
i love spending time with my kids
especially since i don't see them much
during the week but
i think it's the freedom yes if he can
say well i'm gonna go do this today and
i'm like okay i guess you're going to do
that today but but
the resentment there is
and it's a comment it's a common
resentment it's not that well yeah you
said it perfectly it's not like you want
to be out hunting
it's that
you want him to
want to
fulfill your picture of what a saturday
would look like
here's two incredible things okay
number one my guess is and you could say
john you are wrong we are good at this
if you're good at it you would be in the
one percent of the one percent okay of
married couples with two kids two and
two and under
is
have you heard me talk about pictures
and words here
yes okay
is that you that's my listener come on
okay you have a very clear picture in
your head of what
time is
with family family time looks like
and
that we're not doing a great job of
communicating that to your husband and
he has a very clear understanding of
here's what i need
and he
communicates that with i'm going to go
kayaking every day because my guess is
kayaking or getting out in nature
whatever the thing is also fuels a
couple of things for him number one he
has two kids
uh two and under and he feels like he's
lost his wife
number two he's got two kids two and
under and
he loves his kids with all of his heart
but he's got some skills that he doesn't
understand and so it's natural to want
to lean into the things that i'm good at
i i know how to hide in the woods and
shoot a deer i do not know how to
entertain a seven month old
and without some intentionality i'm just
going to
lean this away and if this hobby doesn't
fulfill it i'll find this one and this
one i'll fulfill all we're doing is just
trying to find something that's going to
fill that gap
and
now we're just talking past each other
my guess is he would want more than
anything in the world is to be a
participant in the life of his wife and
kids
and
being out in nature going out and
exhaling and finding past hobbies and
things like that are really important
for people so it's twofold you need to
find some hobbies
okay and you all need to come to terms
with hey so i'm a big hunter i'm out i
don't talk about a lot cause i know it's
people don't like it um yeah i'm out in
the woods a lot a lot a lot and this
past fall i traveled all over
and so my wife and i had some
conversation like
like here's what i need i can't i i need
you your presence here
and i need she's got things that she
likes to do so i need to go do my
hobbies too and so i had to make peace
with i'm on the road a lot so the time
i'm going to spend in the woods is going
to be less this year but it's a
conversation we we had together but it
was very needs-based not i need you here
just sitting on the couch no no right i
need your son and daughter neither daddy
and here's what that looks like and
i need you to be on the floor with us i
need you to be here for four hours
because i need to go
do some hiking on my own right
instead of saying well you get to do
this and i get to do that and so now i'm
just pissed off and i'm mad at you you
know what i mean because then it becomes
about the hobby and the hobby is not the
issue the issue is
i've got a picture of what this
weekend's going to look like and you
have a picture of the week is going to
look like and now we're just talking
past each other
does that make sense i think yep that
makes perfect and all of that on top of
your body's a human jungle gym
nobody's sleeping and you're working
he's
probably not made the adjustment like
most most most young dads don't make the
adjustment on
your domestic responsibilities increase
50 percent i need you here and here's
what i need from you here's what this
looks like
and so having a conversation about what
needs look like and y'all have to do
that probably every month or two because
they're going to change these kids are
going to change like crazy
is that hard can he hear that
yeah yeah i mean i understand what
you're saying yeah but you don't like
that tell me we don't like it no no no
it's not that i like it it's a it's a
communication thing that that we need to
work on i mean i see what you're saying
but i hadn't really i had been focusing
so much on the actual hobby
but i don't think i was looking i was
you know zooming out and looking at
maybe it's not the fact that he does x
or y it's the idea behind why he's doing
it so i think i think that makes sense
let me say it this way
um
there's a like
him walking in all gross and dirty and
stinky
covered in camouflage whatever
at dark and he had said he's gonna be
back at two or three and he gets back at
dark
and
you're mad and you start telling
yourself stories about being mad and
what he's doing out there and he doesn't
appreciate all the crap you do and you
work a job to like you're right so the
story machine is running and he gets
home and you're like i can't no more
hunting no more
there's that
and then there's a
tuesday evening after the kids are down
and you'll exhale and you have a weekly
what's our picture look like for this
week meeting
and you look at him across the table and
say i miss
you i miss you
and everything in our world has blown up
it's all different it's good but it's
all different now and i'm tired you're
tired we're both working really hard
i miss you
and we got to rebuild something new we
got to recreate something new because a
human's multiple human bombs have gone
off in our home and so we're going to
we're going to rebuild something new
that's a totally different conversation
because it will eventually get to
the story i tell myself is every free
moment you have you'd rather spend it
not with us
that is the story
right but if you tell him you'd rather
be hunting than being with your kids
now i'm lobbing grenades if you tell
them the story i'm telling myself is you
would rather be sitting in the woods
covered in a dead animal's blood than
holding your kids
that's the story you're telling and
that's a much different approach
one of those turns him on his default
setting and he's gonna get he's gonna
get uh
sunday dad grumpy right
um or he's gonna get angry and yell
which one is he yeah
uh angry and y'all okay yeah
uh hey
you're always yelling around here no no
no
hey it scares me when you yell
see the difference there it makes me
feel unsafe when you yell and scream
like a child in the house
i'd much rather you go for a walk and
then come back and say hey uh here's
what i'm struggling with or wrestling
with
those two approaches get to the same
issue but one is a path of war and one
is a path of
hey help me out here because i don't
feel safe or the story i tell myself i'm
taking ownership of this
see the big difference there
i do okay and there's a big difference
you're right yeah i see it i find that
it helps me to write things down before
i enter into a conversation with my wife
on these topics
um
a good example happened just yesterday
and by the way
the more we make these regular
occurrences the better our relationships
get
um
kelly and i and joanna who works in pr
here we did a quick um
like
28 hour trip 36 hour trip to california
which is two time zones out right it's a
long trip
um we had an incredible experience with
the mind pump guys and we're we'll have
some shows coming out about that later
on but great trip the trip was awesome
and as we were coming back we got home
at 4 a.m when i rolled in um and i had a
picture in my head of what homecoming
was going to look like it's 100 a story
i told myself made up the whole thing
and then it didn't happen
and my wife my daughter's going to art
camp and my wife was getting her ready
and it just didn't happen in the way i
had pictured it in my head
and then i started getting defensive
about it and then all of a sudden i find
myself getting mad like i just not mad
like not yelling but i feel mad in my
chest like
man
and then i had to pull the thread on
that very quickly and it was
oh yeah i told myself a story about what
um homecoming was gonna look like and it
doesn't look like that okay
and then i can grieve it real quick and
be like man
and then
my wife and i are going to have our
weekly meeting and i can say hey this
fall when i'm traveling
here's what homecoming like i get these
pictures in my head
of what this looks like and then i feel
like it so i can take ownership of this
and realized that she didn't do anything
to make me mad my wife didn't my
daughter didn't my dogs didn't the
chickens didn't i owned the whole
narrative walking into this
and in this case maybe he is
like i've got friends who are hunters
and fishers fishermen
they disappear it's their mistress it's
they cheat on their spouse with their
hobbies or playing guitar or whatever
the thing is
um i get that
and that's a hard conversation
everybody's got to have but it's always
better done better with the story i'm
choosing to tell myself is this that's a
great entry point versus
if you go hot right
and man mary he's lucky to have you he's
lucky to have you